in life and in death
we give glory
uh hello you shouldn't be out here it's
not safe
what the hell hey can you hear me
it's you the child's father
child hey wait do you mean rose is she
here
rose rose yes
she is in great danger since mother
miranda brought her to the village we
have fallen into
darkness what are you talking about the
monsters
the castle bell herald's danger
they're coming no
wait where's rose who's mother miranda
the bell tolls for us all they're
coming again
i'm here
uh
um
so
guess this leads to the castle
so
mm-hmm
this
uh
hmm
um
okay
huh
ah
uh
foreign
oh
[Applause]
yes
uh
oh
uh
close the door please
hey what are you doing here
stay back please don't hurt us
whoa it's okay i'm not gonna hurt you
i'm just glad to see normal people at
last have you seen any other survivors
no they're all in louise's house
and she's not answering in the gate is
locked quiet girl
he's an outsider
oh
[ __ ] we're setting ducks in here can
your old man walk
no one of the monsters cut him he's lost
a lot of blood we have to get into
louisiana
quiet there must be a way inside
stay here be quiet don't move until i
get those gates open
um
uh
come on it's clear hurry hurry
took your damn time oh you're welcome
he's not used to relying on other people
i'm sorry
we'll be safe in here won't we safe
we're here then out there that's for
sure
hey do you know anything about what's
going on here
it doesn't make any sense mother miranda
has always protected us
nobody's answer
father
we have to get inside
hello anybody home
maybe a familiar voice louisa
open up it's me elena
stop shouting you'll draw the monsters
who's this our friend stay back father
for god's sake julian let us in no
they'll smell the blood you'll endanger
us all
my father will die out here that's not
my problem what's going on
these people want to let a dying man
into our home come now these
people are our friends go on go inside
come now this way
you're not from this village uh
no i'm ethan eulen go make yourself
useful and check the grounds
i said go
well if elena trusts you
then so do i come inside ethan
wait here i'll check on the others
this way
come inside the others are waiting
what the [ __ ] is this outsiders you're
gonna get us all killed
anton he helped leonardo and elena we
were doing fine
by ourselves please ethan take a seat
is this all that's left from your entire
village
all that's left all that's left
there is no one left a worthless
invalid a stupid
whaling [ __ ] and you've
you drag a bloody man and an outsider in
here like it's nothing
and expect to be all safe there is no
safe every sorry bastard out there has
been ripped in half
but tomorrow
tomorrow we'll all be dead
just like her damn husband
roxanna that's enough this house has
protected my family for generations
and drunk or not you are all welcome
and safe in here whatever
can someone please tell me what the hell
is going on here
we don't know one day we were a quiet
devout village and the next the monsters
came
and attacked us and they
they kept coming wait louise where is
your husband
did they no no he he is out there
somewhere he he went to get help
yes yes that's that's it he he went to
fetch help
let us pray for him
for all of us good idea
come gather
great ones hear our voice together
as one in reverence we call on thee
within the endless dark to deliver us
into faith's hands as the midnight moon
rises
on black wings so we make our sacrifice
and await the life at the end
in life and to death
we give you glory mother miranda
no the tea should be ready come help me
elena please
that prayer i've heard it before there
was an old woman near the graveyard
some [ __ ] as crazy as a bag of rats
there is wisdom in her devotion though
and i hope it protected her as it shall
protect us
what are you doing leonardo what's wrong
are you okay
no let me go
okay
[Applause]
i said no
oh my god i'm so sorry father
hey hey that wasn't your father anymore
you did the right thing
[Applause]
elena elena no there's nothing you can
do
this entire place is collapsing
you couldn't save him he was already
gone
leave me alone no we're getting out of
here
together
i gotta get out of here
so
so
damn the fire's moving fast
what are you thinking step back we can
bust out with this
are you all right um i'm fine let me
back up again
the fire there isn't any time
grab on hurry
let's move don't worry
and try not to breathe in the smoke i
know
thank you ethan you're kind
i hope your family is safe i do too once
we get out of here maybe you'll get to
meet them
come on hit a hole
there that's our way out oh thank god
but what then the village is still full
of monsters
we can't fight them there's too many hey
hey don't talk like that we'll find a
safe house to put you in until i can
find my daughter
my hunch is she's in that old castle no
that place is full of nothing but blood
and death
and i don't want to be alone while
you're father
elena no that's not him not anymore
he said my name father wait it's not
safe
stay there
come on give me your hand
ethan go save your daughter
elena don't give up
reach for me
why is everyone dying on me
this is just too much
i just don't get it
this place is going mad
why the [ __ ] is this happening again
[ __ ]
hey
[Laughter]
who was what was that
death yes
death has visited them all
ah
uh
[Music]
nothing but blood and death huh
you